quand vous avez des connaissances
mondaine ils ont voulu monter ils ont
souhaité festoyer avec nous ce soir mais
malheureusement ils sont pas dans les
murs ils ont ils vous en effet des
vidéos pour gérer leur fermer sa g
mathieu est ce que vous pouvez me le
dire dans vos mots à la même en moi
comme vous avez évidemment des
connaissances avec la mondaine puisque
vous avez que la montre il n'a pas été
prouvé encore retenu comme vous avez des
connaissances avec la mondaine pas venir
j'ai mal au total en vidéo
eh ben on va regarder il paraît que
c'est une surprise pour moi en tout cas
c'est bien vendu entre les deux certains
n'ont rien laissé partir mon gars je
pense à un piper b to you parcours fait
ton anniversaire aujourd'hui
moi aussi je souhaite un bon
anniversaire à mon ami en arabe bbb tun
ousseynou nature on connaît ses cales du
thé dears e anniversaire porter 50 ans
je vais dire un joyeux anniversaire à 10
sur l'homme dans un pub et fait mourir
fais nous rêver ça qui fait plein de
choses que je veux chanter un joyeux
anniversaire
un happy birthday to you culturel gros
big up a toi inviteront baba bon
anniversaire
on est avec toi quel avec nous papa
c'est à vous merci à la verticale du
à lui tordre ils attendent à wels arias
veille avaient tous là ce trailer est
franchement et au marais qui nous a fait
plein de riches on oubliera et c'est
merci ça fait hyper plaisir sans
déconner c'est fort merci mais non merci
mélanie alors manger une petite surprise
pour eux
pour vous c'est quelqu'un qui voulait
vous souhaiter un bon anniversaire qui a
pas pu venir malheureusement mais il a
tenu à vous laisser un message
regardez ça lui s'il sait nicolas
sarkozy des informations très précises
ont indiqué que c'était votre
anniversaire
ces informations n'ont paniqué nage je
voulais vous dire que j'aime votre
énergie que j'aime notre enthousiasme
que parfois même je peux me reconnaître
bon anniversaire syrie
alors lui comme un fou à la mairie en
tout cas je remercie nicolas the ring et
empêche pas de politique on a les jack
lang à gauche ouais donc ça va voilà on
mérite plus qu'un gars au milieu en fait
on attend françois bayrou françois
bayrou si nous écoutent voilà si tu peux
envoyer un petit tweet
voilà ça nous ferait plaisir et melançon
à l'extrême gauche voilà le reste c'est
bon merci au plus tard à bercy peut
pratiquer avec les remercie vivement que
son cabas merci en tout cas ça me fait
plaisir à tous et jule aussi quel
bonheur j'espère qu'il va venir nous
voir les chéris alors